on this tuesday night decriminalizing
drugs
bc's bold move to combat the opioid
crisis this is not legalization
we have not taken this decision lightly
in a north america first firearms
legislation unholstered we're also
looking at drug policy because the drug
trade is the engine of gang violence the
reaction to canada's clap down on guns
agony and outrage in uvalde i wake up
every morning and the first thing i do
is cry because i know that it's real as
the grieving texas community begins
laying school shooting victims to rest
plus turning off the taps to russian oil
how the european union has been funding
a war it's fighting against
and the mouth-watering guide to canada's
best restaurants so who takes the cake
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
good evening and thank you for joining
us 27 000 canadians have died from
opioid related overdoses since 2016.
tonight the federal government is taking
action to address the crisis in one of
the worst hit provinces british
columbians who possess up to 2.5 grams
of illicit drugs for personal use will
not be arrested or charged starting
early next year the federal minister of
mental health and addiction said
granting the exemption is a significant
policy change needed to slow the public
health emergency this is not
legalization
we have not taken this decision lightly
no longer criminally prohibiting
personal possession of small amounts of
certain controlled substances is just
one tool in a full range of solutions to
fight the overdose crisis that we are
facing
the three-year exemption will apply to
drug users 18 and over and include
opioids cocaine methamphetamine and mdma
also known as ecstasy
bc legislative bureau chief keith baldry
has been following this announcement and
joins us now with more so keith this is
a dramatic shift in canada's drug policy
what are the details and what could it
mean for other provinces
it is a significant shift one of the
biggest ones we've seen in quite some
time nido again you listed some of the
drugs involved here which does include
opioids cocaine methamphetamine again it
applies only to adults age 18 and over
these drugs are still criminalized in
such settings as schools child carers
and airports so that's not going to
change and it's going to take some time
to phase phases and police have to be
trained under the new rules
not quite what the bc government was
looking for here they were looking for
personal possession up to four and a
half grams it's now set at two and a
half grams also hoping it could be
implemented quicker but certainly bc
getting a list a little bit what it was
looking for from ottawa and it's been a
long hard slog i think out here looking
for that change in drug laws nationally
and in bc on that note this is the
latest in a number of steps that bc has
taken to try and tackle the crisis but
deaths have continued to rise why do
officials believe this change will have
a broader impact
yes one of the things we've seen in the
pandemic is increasing
use of drugs on a
self basis with no one else in the room
so people are isolating in the in the
pandemic and again using drugs in a
dangerous situation with no one there to
watch over them so the feeling is this
could remove the stigmatization that
comes with drug use and allow people to
be more comfortable if they're engaged
in drug use with other people also
interesting today hearing from bc public
health officer dr bonnie henry about
some of the demographic changes that
could be affected here by
decriminalizing drugs indigenous people
pay a disproportionately high cost in
terms of encouragement when it comes to
minor drug possession here's dr henry
over half of the women in our provincial
correctional facilities are indigenous
women and 80 percent of the women in
those facilities are there for low-level
drug crimes and the disruption that has
on their lives and the lives of their
families and their communities is
immense
so obesity is going first on this front
but already montreal and edmonton are
seeking similar applications here so i
think again based on the data we see
here if the number of deaths does start
to decline significantly in british
columbia as a result of these changes
starting early next year you can be sure
this is probably going to apply to other
jurisdictions as well keith baldery in
victoria bc tonight thanks keith
canada's auditor general is out with
four new reports which find the federal
government is falling short on
supporting disabled veterans and a
number of other vulnerable groups across
the country
these audits point to long-standing
problems and barriers
across a broad range of government
activity
these barriers are unacceptable
whether faced by indigenous and black
offenders or by low-income individuals
and veterans accessing benefits
a.g karen hogan says even with steps
taken towards improving conditions
disabled veterans are still waiting
almost 40 weeks to receive benefits in
some cases hogan also found black
indigenous and female inmates face
greater barriers when returning to
society including timely access to
programs that help with integration
a day after proposing new legislation to
limit handguns in canada there are
questions about how the measure will
take shape bill c-21 stops short of an
outright ban on handguns and instead
would set a hard limit on the number of
weapons in the country
those who currently own and
operate handguns safely and store them
safely are not at all targeted by this
legislation we're simply saying
that we are freezing the market and in
the future it will not be possible to
buy sell transfer or import handguns in
canada
until the legislation passes the federal
government will monitor and collect data
on any new handguns that are purchased
abigail beeman has more
i'm angry
like i'm angry and i'm frustrated
because we follow the rules in the wake
of the liberals new gun legislation it's
no surprise people like gun range owner
j.r cox feel targeted it doesn't look
good for the business it doesn't look
good for me while gun control advocates
like ken price and claire smith whose
daughter samantha survived the danforth
shooting in toronto are pleased by a
handgun freeze i'm just a bit in shock
at the news
i'm really
i'm really encouraged and i'm very very
thankful but the legislation is
complicated with much to unpack experts
are divided as to whether new rules will
have an impact on the problem of illegal
guns entering canada it absolutely will
work for police it'll also work for
local municipalities because they will
have the ability to implement certain
bylaws which will restrict weapons also
thinking that we can actually stop them
at the border
is
in my view dreaming ervin waller says
we'll never know how many illegal guns
flow through the border he is among
those who believe the only way to stop
them is to lower demand by tackling the
causes of gang violence economic
opportunity job opportunities stuff like
that but we're also looking at drug
policy because the drug trade is the
engine of gang violence something
everyone but the government seems to
agree on expect a short-term burst in
gun sales and licensing as people try to
beat the deadline when the freeze takes
hold and you can't buy new guns it is a
ban in everything but name gun law
expert solomon friedman says the
legislation was put forward without
enough consultation on all sides it
seems to me like gun control made by
twitter that in the wake of an awful
unspeakable tragedy in the united states
which of course has its own gun culture
has its own issues with respect to
violence that simply do not exist in
canada
we have some really shoddy legislation
the public safety minister certainly
disagrees believing the bill's new
surveillance and wiretap powers for
investigators and tougher sentences are
effective deterrents for illegal gun
users he's also promising to move
forward on the long-standing gun buyback
promise now three years old and not
included in the legislation abigail
beeman global news ottawa
two rcmp decision makers were granted
permission to testify via pre-recorded
video interviews today at a public
inquiry into one of canada's worst mass
shootings the managers were also exempt
from undergoing cross-examination by
lawyers for families of the 22 victims
as ross lord reports what the mounties
said sheds more light on their failure
to contain the gunman for 13 hours in
2020
questioning by the mass casualty
commission was cordial
that's uh
the type of
explanation i think that that
helps certainly myself and hopefully
others understand
free from cross-examination by family
lawyers an rcmp decision maker explained
his part on the maori's response to the
nova scotia massacre that left 22 people
murdered there are going to be crossed
wires there are going to be duplication
of efforts when first called at home
andy o'brien declined to become involved
in the response because he'd consumed
several glasses of rum there's a
person down there with a gun
they're still looking for him but
o'brien did take a lead role despite the
rcmp's code of conduct that forbids
members from working if they've been
drinking and did you feel
at any point in the course of that
evening that you were in breach of this
code of conduct
no on the following day members guarded
several murder scenes in portobeck nova
scotia they did not check for additional
scenes it for some reason never occurred
to me that there might be other scenes
many families are boycotting the
hearings saying the maudi's protected
testimony amounts to a lack of
accountability the commission has
alluded to unspecified health concerns
they have to give a more clear
explanation to the affected
families of the victims as to why
they're doing this another rcmp manager
staff sergeant brian rehill says he
didn't hear a member's radio message
about an alternate community road a road
the killer used as an escape route
before killing nine more people the
following day
ross lord global news windsor nova
scotia
in uvalde texas today the first of the
funerals for the children killed in the
school shooting friends and loved ones
said their final goodbyes to two
ten-year-old girls gunned down in their
classroom one week ago jennifer johnson
has the latest
more pain and mourning in uvalde as the
first of 21 funerals are held for two
schoolchildren killed in last week's
mass shooting ten-year-old amari joe
garza was shot to death while trying to
call 9-1-1 from her classroom
mate rodriguez was an honor roll student
who dreamed of becoming a marine
biologist she didn't deserve it but
i just know in that moment she was brave
she was telling people where to hide
the grief in uvalde is impossible to
measure a texas artist is creating
unique caskets for each of the 19
children killed hoping to honor who they
were it's not about just painting a
casket it's about helping those families
to start their healing process as family
members lay their children to rest
ivaldi's police chief who stopped
officers from going into the classroom
for 47 minutes last week was supposed to
be sworn in as a new city council member
that was canceled but a push to tear
down the school is gaining support i
would never ask expect a child to have
to ever walk in those doors ever
and ever again on capitol hill senators
met to seek middle ground a new gun
control legislation including stricter
background checks
john corton is the republican senator
from texas chris murphy a democrat
represents connecticut where 26 people
most of them children were killed at
sandy hook in 2012. i've been
to more
mass shooting after mass than i think
any present american history
unfortunately at the white house
president joe biden met with new
zealand's prime minister who put into
effect sweeping gun reforms after the
deadly 2019 shootings in christchurch
but in texas there will only be more
funerals for now including for teacher
eva morellis who died trying to protect
her school children her sister had to
pick out the dress ava will be buried in
that was the hardest thing that i've
ever had to do in my life and never in
my dreams thought that
that my sister was not going to make it
a heartache shared by so many in this
small community jennifer johnson global
news washington
crude oil prices rose today after the
european union agreed to reduce its
imports of russian oil by up to 90
percent by the end of the year the plan
could cut off moscow from tens of
billions of dollars worth of funds
redmond shannon has more
a ukrainian court sentences another two
russian soldiers for war crimes this
time to 11 and a half years each in
prison for shelling a village in eastern
ukraine investigation processes and then
court processes will be very long period
of time ukraine's prosecutor general
says her office has now identified 600
russian war crime suspects on the front
lines in the east russian troops have
now taken parts of sierra donetsk the
bombarded city an important target for
the kremlin as it aims to control the
entire donbass region
president vladimir zelinsky called the
situation there very difficult as he
accepted a pledge of artillery from
slovakia as president but slovakia along
with the czech republic and hungary is
exempt from a newly agreed european
union ban on russian oil imports by the
end of the year the country will
effectively benefit
from from this exemption
without the necessity of playing the
role of the bad boy or the black male or
what what orban
used to play
hungarian leader victor orban led
objections to an all-encompassing eu ban
calling it unbearable for his country's
economy
germany's economic minister carl
dorban's desire for an exemption
short-sighted and self-interested this
is a topic where we will come back to
and
where we will still have to work on but
it is a big step forward according to
one estimate the eu has paid russia more
than 77 billion canadian dollars for
fossil fuels since the war began
effectively funding the russian war
chest more than half of that money spent
on oil most of the rest natural gas the
gas is of course much more
difficult than than oil already was
all the next sanctions will be more
difficult and that's especially true
because germany and its population of 85
million relies so heavily on that
natural gas redmond shannon global news
london
coming up rethinking retirement how some
canadians are concerned they won't have
enough cash to call it quits
the canadian economy is growing thanks
in part to business investment and
household spending statistics canada
says the gross domestic product or gdp
grew at an annual rate of 3.1 percent in
the first quarter of this year but
that's well below consensus estimates
and down from 6.6 percent in the last
quarter of 2021 but the bank of canada
says the economy is running too hot
experts say the central bank will likely
raise its key interest rate target
wednesday by half a percentage point
bringing it to 1.5 percent to try to
cool skyrocketing inflation
rising costs are forcing about a third
of canadians to rethink their retirement
date according to a new rbc survey
inflation means everyday spending takes
a bigger bite out of fixed budgets for
those already retired and gaviola
examines what these increases mean for
retirement in the final installment of
her sticker shock series
i felt like the life had been sucked out
of me working
retail
was brutal brutal for the last two and a
half years mary lou seer is part of a
cohort of people who retired early
during the pandemic but as stock markets
remained turbulent interest rates climb
and inflation soars it's a challenging
time to be living on a fixed income i do
have a small savings
but it's going to erode very quickly
with inflation
a good rule of thumb is you need 70 to
80 percent of your current income in
retirement to maintain your lifestyle
but with inflation clocking in at nearly
7 percent levels we haven't seen in 31
years many are reconsidering this
approach personal finance expert patti
lovett reed is newly semi-retired
spending more time with her growing
family and renovating but still keeping
busy with a variety of side hustles she
recommends a personal assessment of what
your unique situation is including your
debt and how inflation is affecting you
the global news personal inflation
calculator at globalnews.ca can help you
figure out your personal rate of
inflation to help you take action you
have to tweak lifestyles when you're
thrown a curveball we have been thrown a
big curveball we're not striking out yet
but we've got that curveball three
strategies for managing unexpected costs
during retirement include increasing
your income whether that's picking up
some extra work or maybe tapping into
the equity built up in your home
reducing spending in areas where you can
are there subscriptions or services you
can do without and if necessary consider
downsizing your home your lifestyle
i lived through the early 1980s we do
get through this but it never happens as
quickly as you would like flexibility is
key whether it applies to your
retirement date or how you'll be
spending a portion of your golden years
ann gaviola global news toronto
delayed takeoff ahead why canada's
pandemic border restrictions aren't
going away just yet
canada is now extending its covet 19
border restrictions until at least june
30th the public health agency of canada
announced this on tuesday a day after
parliament voted down a conservative
opposition motion to go back to
pre-pandemic travel rules this means
restrictions are still in place at
canadian airports and land borders
including random covit 19 testing and
vaccine mandates all international
travelers will also still need to use
the arrive can app before coming to
canada
china's largest city took major steps
towards reopening today after enduring a
strict two-month lockdown due to coven
19. authorities in shanghai reopen
transit basic rail connections with the
rest of china and will gradually reopen
schools and shops in the coming days
plans have also been introduced to
support the city's economy which has
been hit hard by the restrictions
well we hope we're not hungry next a
delicious look at canada's best
restaurants
after years of covered measures strained
both the restaurant industry and our
appetites it's no surprise many
canadians are rushing out for dinner
these days now they may have more reason
to as the latest list of canada's 100
best restaurants is finally out after a
starvingly long hiatus mike trolley
takes a closer look
there's nothing ostentatious about
vancouver's published on maine in fact
blink and you might drive right past the
winner of canada's top 100 best
restaurants list
canada's best represents the entire
country unlike the famed michelin guide
which is in the process of raiding
toronto's restaurants
so toronto's aloe which finished second
after being atop canada's best four
times is judged on the same level as
calgary's major tom which was named best
new restaurant yeah i'm gonna go one two
chef one canada has always had great
restaurants but there's always been a
reticence to name any of them best that
wouldn't be considered very canadian but
now especially as we emerge from the
pandemic chefs like toronto's rob rossi
whose osteria julia finished second in
the new restaurant category couldn't be
happier for the increased scrutiny i
know that a lot of restauranteurs and
chefs and you know all the cooks and
everybody that that makes these
restaurants function
it's very important to them this is our
life passion and uh
you know it's it's just something that
we really need and we want to give back
to back to the people and we the people
clearly want to get back to them andrew
smith who runs the toronto wine club
curatus sees a return of customer
confidence and business deals such as
the one he made to be the official
canadian ambassador of basketball legend
yao ming's wines are once again flowing
you know it's as much as it's as it's
deserved it's very affirming to the to
the folks like me who have who have
stuck with it pivoted lasted and now we
can open again
and people can kind of relish and
celebrate it we can all raise a glass to
that
microlight global news toronto
and that is global national for this
tuesday i'm nitu garcia tonight's your
canada is a rainbow over lake huron in
midland ontario we love to see your
canada please email it to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching have a good night
[Music]
you